>> ♪ ♪
>> Bret: TONIGHT THE POLITICS OF
DRUGS.
THEY ARE AT THE HART OF A SENATE
RACE IN WEST VIRGINIA.
3 REPUBLICANS VYING FOR THE GOP
NOMINATION HAVE THEIR OWN IDEAS
TO COMBAT OPIOIDS ABUSE.
>> THE CANDIDATES SPENT TIME IN
COURT, CONGRESS OR A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
NOW REPUBLICANS COMPETING IN
WEST VIRGINIA'S SENATE PRIMARY
ARE FIGHTING ABOUT WHO IS IN
BEST POSITION TO FIGHT THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
>> WE HAVE TACKLED THE PROBLEM.
>> THE STATE'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
TOOK CREDIT FOR A COURT VICTORY
FOR A NEW DEA-RULE TO CUT DOWN
ON OPIOID PRODUCTION.
>> PART OF THE REASON WHY WE
SUED THE DEA IS WE FOUND OUT
THAT THE NATIONAL DRUG QUOTA
SYSTEM HAS FAILED OUR CITIZENS.
>> IN WASHINGTON, CONGRESS CUT
THE CHECKS FOR OPIOID PREVENTION
AND TREATMENT.
THE ONLY CANDIDATE SERVING THERE
IS CONGRESSMAN EVAN JENKINS.
>> I SERVED ON COMMITTEES.
THE $6 BILLION WORKING WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT WE JUST
APPROVED IS A SIGNIFICANT
POSITIVE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> JENKINS WHO HELPED START A
RECOVERY CENTER FOR INFANTS BORN
TO DRUG ADDICTED MOTHERS.
>> IF A PERSON HAS DEEP ROOTS
AND RELATIONSHIPS FROM ALL OF
HIS LOBBYING EXPERIENCE WITH BIG
PHARMACEUTICALS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE CAN TRUST
HIM.
>> I DON'T THINK HE CAN MAKE
THAT CLAIM.
>> JENKINS IS A HYPOCRITE.
HE TOOK MASSIVE QUANTITIES OF
MONEY FROM THE PHARMACEUTICALS
INDUSTRY.
>> AND A CONTENDER FRESH OUT OF
PRISON.
DON BLANKENSHIP WHO SPENT A YEAR
ON MISDEMEANOR CHARGES.
>> ENDING THE SANCTUARY CITIES
IS IMPORTANT AND DRUG TESTING
TEACHERS, JUDGES AND PROSECUTORS
IS IMPORTANT.
>> HIS IDEAS MIRROR THE
PRESIDENT AND HE BELIEVES
JENKINS AND MORRISEY HAD A
CHANCE AND BLEW IT.
>> I THINK BOTH ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE EPIDEMIC BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH.
>> IT'S RARE FOR THERE TO BE A
COMPETITIVE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
IN THIS STATE.
THIS IS THE MOST DETAILS THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE GOTTEN IN
DEBATES ABOUT OPIOIDS IN YEAR.
THERE IS URGENCY BECAUSE THE CDC